اللافتة عبارة عن تحذير، احذر من الألغام،
فالغابة بمثابة حماية أيضًا، وهي
شاشة طبيعية تخفي سرًا كبيرًا
هنا بين الأشجار على بعد حوالي ساعة
بالسيارة شمال كييف، توجد بقايا
معسكر عسكري روسي مترامي الأطراف
تظهرنا حوله القوات الخاصة الأوكرانية.
يقول الجندي إن المواقع كانت تحت سيطرة
مشاة البحرية الروسية،
نرى شبكة مترامية الأطراف من
مواقع القتال تحت الأرض،
ومراكز القيادة، ومناطق النوم، وتخزين الذخيرة،
بينما يوجد في كل مكان دليل على
الطريقة التي عاش بها الروس، وتشير هذه الأدلة إلى أن
وجودهم هنا
لم يكن منضبطًا ولا مريحًا، بل
هو كذلك  الهدوء هنا الآن فقط بعض
ضجيج الطيور ونسيم خفيف ولكن في الآونة الأخيرة
كان هناك ستة آلاف جندي روسي
يبيتون في هذه
الغابة في معسكر
كبير جدًا بحيث لا يمكنك رؤية أين يبدأ
وأين ينتهي
العيش هنا كان من الصعب العيش هنا  كان
خلال أبرد أيام الشتاء لمدة
أربعة أسابيع
توقفوا هنا بالقرب من كييف
بعد أن فشلوا في الاستيلاء على العاصمة
بسرعة، تم
كسر الصمت من خلال الجهود المبذولة للتعامل
مع بعض القوانين غير المحددة،
يعد هذا المعسكر دليلاً دامغًا على
إخفاقات روسيا على هذه الجبهة، حيث أن الإعداد السيئ كان
خاطئًا للغاية  افتراضات حول
الأعداد والموارد اللازمة لغزو
كييف،
ما هي الدروس التي تستخلصها من كل
هذا والتي ستنطبق على
المعركة القادمة من أجل دونباس في الشرق؟
يقول إننا نرى حجم القوات التي
غزت هذه المنطقة ونفهم ذلك
تكون هذه القوة أكبر بمرتين إلى ثلاث مرات في
منطقة دونباس،
ولم تقتصر هذه القوة على الغابة، حيث
عاش ضباطها القياديون بشكل
أكثر راحة في القرية المجاورة
حيث يروي المدنيون
قصصًا مألوفة بشكل مثير للقلق، ويقول ميكانيكي محلي
إنه تم احتجازه واستجوابه
لمدة 24 عامًا تقريبًا
يقول إنه تعرض للضرب معصوب العينين
وتعرض لعمليات إعدام وهمية
[موسيقى]
يقول إنه لم يعرف خوفًا مثله أبدًا
وكان يعتقد دائمًا أن تلك كانت
لحظاته الأخيرة على الأرض يصف الكاهن المحلي
فاسيلي بينسر التعامل مع
عواقب قسوة أكبر، كما
يقول  وجد خمسة رجال يتعرضون للتعذيب والقتل
في الحديقة،
واثنين آخرين في الغابة،
وأحضر له الروس امرأتين ميتتين وطلبوا منه
دفنهما، بينما خيم
الروس الآخرون في هذه المنطقة
في الحقول مع قطع مدفعيتهم
وسرقوا ما يمكنهم من وسائل الراحة من
فراش.  الكحول من أعمال
شكسبير،
لذلك من مواقع إطلاق النار هذه،
طارت صواريخ الغراد عبر السماء
باتجاه هوستيمال التي لا
تبعد سوى مسافة قصيرة نسبيًا، وعندما
ضربت الأرض
كان المدنيون في كثير من الأحيان هم الذين شعروا بقوتهم،
يمكنك رؤية النتيجة،
كان هناك الكثير من الناس  يختبئ هناك نعم في مقيم معادي
ديمتري نيكازاكوف يظهر
آثار ضربة صاروخية روسية،
هذا هو مركز الانفجار
وحيث تم دفن بعض ضحاياه
مؤقتًا،
أشعر فقط بالكراهية
الشديدة نعم
لا يمكننا أن نغفر ذلك لفترة
طويلة
ربما مدى الحياة
الآن غادر الأعداء في حقول الغابات
والقرى هذا الجزء من
أوكرانيا،
وبقيت ثمار إقامتهم القصيرة
وصدمة الألم والبغض